plastic is the new paper hello i'm paper
bottle
saving the earth how's it going everyone
my name is
[Applause]
i hate bad design fellow sink hater here
today we're looking at some of the worst
design ever made hello i'm paper bottle
saving the error i love that that's so
insane chipotle goes all out advertising
that for the next week delivery is free
and then casually makes the delivery
mini price higher than the regular one
oh
free delivery you just pay more amazing
it's not it's not a bad idea i don't i
don't hate that one
what i'm kidding having to watch the 30
seconds of ads before i'm even able to
pump gas let's go
oh my god
the industrial rep no
cup design that makes the drink look
like it has actual fruit in it
how can they keep getting away with it
there's no strawberry mixture in that
it's just plastic
ah
the worst one of them all
god damn it we're three ones and i'm
pissed off where's that so you go if
you'd like to unsubscribe from our
emails please consider donating that i'm
pretty sure that's illegal there's no
way they can do that you have to pay to
unsubscribe you can just block their
email come on so in china they have a
toilet paper dispenser that requires you
to watch a 30 second ads before you give
to toilet paper it only gives you about
three per head and people thought i was
crazy when i said everything is getting
[ __ ]
everything is getting
everything even me norton after
canceling subscription your subscription
is over
really of it how how has it become that
antivirus programs became actual viruses
and they won't stop haggling you or
harassing you to keep activating that
shut the [ __ ] up you became you became
the thing you you swore to destroy
windows 10 update silently turns on news
weather and taskbar links default uh
yeah yeah it's great the first thing you
have to do when you install the new os
now is just like okay turn this off turn
this off turn this off turn this on and
spend like an hour just removing all
this stuff that they set up for you
why would they oh they made them seem
longer
hey at least they remove the head for
you i'm not gonna eat that
i'm not that mad at this i don't know
why
the difference between a small versus a
medium orange juice at mcdonald's i will
see these and i never know if it's
actually real or not yep that seems
about right i've definitely had this
sandwich thank you weight rose yeah
those are so tiny there's and they
advertise is like like super low calorie
it's like look you can get this low
calorie
lunch and then it's like no food inside
wow it's so healthy look how small
[Laughter]
stop struggling with those stubborn
plastic packages
oh
it's going to be locked in there forever
i mean how are you possibly going to get
that out if only you had another package
of the stomach
i actually know a life hack this is one
of those few life hacks i saw if you get
your fingers in the in the hole there
and then just oh you can do that just
saying i don't know if i explained that
well but yeah 64 crayon colors you like
orange right
you [ __ ] love orange don't you oh my
god it even shows the colors on top are
you kidding me
why do some of them make me laugh and
others just make me really angry maybe
it's because i wouldn't buy these uh
pencils even though they're very cute
[Laughter]
make sure you pick the right one we made
them very different so you don't make a
mistake one is going to give you a nice
relaxing time the other one not so much
[Laughter]
there you go bro
grab one from the fridge grab a cold one
from the fridge enjoy yeah
it tastes good
oh boy this tastes good man oh it's
radiator coolant i love radiator coolant
it tastes so good so cold and nice hell
yeah
this packaging i mean at least it's
cardboard right like we either wrap
plastic and everything these days am i
right fellas you know at least this
cardboard and i understand they need
people to find the product i don't no
this doesn't make me that angry this
should be illegal
come on
prison yeah this prison the final boss
of misleading packages is lace potato
chips new bigger size i guarantee you
they have the same amount in them what
the [ __ ] how did they say it's bigger
customers angry over misleading chip
bags are are suing for getting bags of
air good it's time we strike back
no more
chips
i'm not paying for air doritos
how is it how how does this work explain
this to me 100 juice contains 27 juice
oopsie
i can't believe it how how do they do
that stop it gluten-free chocolate chip
cookie this product contains gluten
here's a crazy idea why not just call it
chocolate chip cookie then what's the
point this one is thirty percent bigger
okay
it was forty percent bigger hmm
okay i guess it's all relative you know
what do you
40 bigger from what it was before i
don't know someone took out all the
raisins
someone someone really spent their whole
afternoon doing that i respect that
salute to you sir beef ravioli it's one
ravioli what's the plural of ravioli it
doesn't say beef ravioli does it idiot
not mad about this i'm reading this
article that shows all this annoying
packaging but what the [ __ ] is this then
this is what it's like to go to mail
online we have them wanting to
give me notifications no thank you we
have an ad here we have an ad here we
have an ad here and we haven't had e
here and then if you scroll down there's
another form of ad
and i also clicked the way the cookie
thing i already clicked that away god
[ __ ] damn it jesus christ dude oh and
it's also auto playing uh it's also
thought i'm playing another ad
ghost on this website just die already
daily mail jesus christ dude this is
pathetic
hello
so one of them has to print that's nice
or two of them the one at the back and
front uh new chairs in starbucks is
specifically designed so people won't
hang around for a long time i mean yeah
how long do you want to sit just
slurping on a coffee i kind of i'm on
the side on starbucks here all those
people just said get an office you can
only study and work if other people are
looking at you so you can prove look
look how busy i am
just work from home stop it
[Laughter]
cancel the subscription to cancel this
contract please send a letter or a fax
to four players
come from hamburg please hand deliver
this cancellation note to the top of
mount everest thanks
oh god
my phone marks
no life has not yet been found on mars
but imagine waking up to that headline
how would you react yeah
imagine imagine that dude i feel like a
lot of these aggregated i don't know if
that's the word news articles that gets
blasted to you for whatever reason
they're all like that okay here here's a
firefox when you open it like who clicks
on this
like i would never trust any of these
head headlines i just imagine how many
people like scroll through them and
they're like yeah yeah sure i heard that
live phone on mars yeah no i heard about
that last week
[Laughter]
oh god
wow so it has two cameras but it
pretends to have uh
four amazing
[Laughter]
you're reading newsweek
i guess that's the end of the article
[Music]
there he goes here continues thanks
what the [ __ ] they're worse than
youtubers la fitness cancellation
process is designed to make you not want
to quit had to go to the gym then call
then send the super later yeah i spent a
month in la and i wanted to work out so
someone recommended la fitness and i
went there and it was awful the way the
amount of harassment i got after
canceling it's like i don't [ __ ] live
there leave me alone
i hate you facebook will start putting
ads in the oculus quest app
can't wait for the sci-fi from the new
world
the meta universe i'm sure facebook is
not going to get up yeah
it didn't used to be like this
it didn't all used to be like this
i've been waiting for this a pill that
gives me treatment the way i want it
hypothetical patient guys subscribe to
the pewdiepie channel and you can win a
billion dollars you could
why is that not even crazy to say at
this point jesus christ anyway if you
enjoyed this video smash it like
subscribe we appreciate it and i'll see
you guys tomorrow with another video
brofist